Nói Mình một tháng 18, thông tin từ công an tình ra lai, đơn vị vừa bắt nằm đối tượng dịch người,
hứa giấm cứ tài sản tại xả lao ngoài, tình ra lai.
Chứ đó, khoảng chiến dự hông qua, người dân địa phương phát hiện tại giấy ở lòng mèo,
xả lao ngoài, một thi tỉn lữ dưới trong từ tế năm rử, trên người có nhiều vết đâm,
gần từ thi có một dơ thế lai.
Ngay sau khi nhận thi báo, đồng chi đại tháng nguyễn ngọt sân, phó rám đốc công an tình đã chức tiếp chỉ đạo
phòng kể rất hiện sự trụ chi.
Phu hợp có đình vị liên quả tiến thành đưa tra, chứ sẽ vời quyết tâm sống chuyến bắt đối tượng
về hán.
Lực lượng công an đánh dân trong xói định nạn như là chỉ giữa mà bé,
xin năm 18, thông tin 2, chú xả lao ngoài, ra lai.
Sáng 18, thông nguyễn năm 18, thông tin xả lao ngoài, tình ra lai đưa con đi học.
Tối cùng ngày, ra đình về khu cây xị bề ở nhà,
đưa la không đường đường nên tổ chức kinh kiếm, kinh nghiênh không thấy.
Đến hình mùi thống nguyễn năm 18, thông tin dịch được thông báo từ cỡ quan công an
bởi đánh dịch giả, xói định tự thi là chỉ bây, khi quả khám nghiệp, công an
phát hiện một con xói thế lãn và giấu vết tình dịch trường người nạn nhân,
trên người nạn nhân khóc phát hiện định thoại sẽ mô tốt của nạn nhân của không tình thấy,
nạn nhân từ bong giò xuy tình hoàn xí hô hấp dò đà với thường.
Chỉ trong vòng cám dự xói phát hiện nạn nhân đến mùi bày dựng hình mùi thống nguyễn năm 18, thông tin dịch giả
hình thái nhận khoảng 12 giờ người mùi thống 18, thông tin đi đến nhà thời giao xử
yên tốt thị gập xị bê đối tượng xin đi nhở xe để vê.
Trong quả hình dịch trình, đối tượng này xin ý định có tài sản đến tiến trở nạn nhân
vào phút cuộc sĩ trình.
Tại đây, đối tượng ý nghĩa và dùng giò tình công nạn nhân, sau đó hức giâm giới
cơ xe mùi tốt và để thoại xí động giới bỏ chốn.
Hình cơ quan công an đắt thủ giữa xe mùi tốt và để thoại xí động tiếp tục được nguyễn, làm gió.